l'union des étudiants juifs de france a
décidé de porter plainte contre le
serveur internet français multimania qui
a hébergé à son insu un site néo nazis
des pages à la gloire de hitler et des
ss une affaire qui illustre la difficile
lutte contre la multiplication des sites
negad négationnistes ou encore
antisémite qui fleurissent sur le net le
reportage d'emmanuel gagner et marc
savinaud la preuve du délit
des tirages papier d'un site néo nazis
que ces étudiants ont découvert hier sur
internet des textes et des photos à la
gloire du troisième reich
hébergé par un serveur informatique
français l'incitation à la haine raciale
incitation au meurtre il ya plusieurs
délits qui sont répréhensibles par la
justice française il ya des lois pour
l'uejf demandait ce que ces lois
aujourd'hui soit soient mises en oeuvre
aujourd'hui le site néo nazis a disparu
des écrans
mais l'union des étudiants juifs de
france a décidé de porter plainte contre
multiples serveurs qui accueillit le
site héberge aujourd'hui français s'est
rendu complice d'un cc rendu complice
d'incitation à la haine raciale
aucun problème là dessus multimania la
société incriminée et dans le langage
des internautes un portail de
communautés grand public un espace sur
le net où l'on peut venir discuter ou
chacun peut créer son propre site et
s'exprimer normalement dans les limites
de la loi manifestation multimania
aujourd'hui héberge plus de 3 2 millions
de pages web qui sont visités par plus
du quart de la population des
internautes français chaque mois donc ça
représente un volume de données
astronomiques que nous ne sommes pas
capables de contrôler de manière
exhaustive
difficile de tout contrôler c'est bien
la question d'internet et les
extrémistes de tout poil profitent des
facilités offertes par le réseau pour
diffuser leur message de haine dans le
monde aujourd'hui plus de 4000 signes
néo nazis auraient été recensés olivier
iteanu est avocat pour lui l'arsenal
juridique français suffisant pour lutter
contre ce phénomène
le problème est ailleurs la question qui
se pose la question de l'efficacité des
décisions judiciaires qui sont prises et
qui vont être prises et notamment pour
celles qui sont prises à l'encontre
d'auteurs qui son site
étrange et donc là c'est vrai que pour
ce vecteur de communication là il faudra
inévitablement une discussion au niveau
international pour que les conventions
d'entraidé judiciaire notamment entre
des états bien se multiplient en france
la dernière grande affaire remonte à fin
97 des néo nazis animés ce site le site
charlemagne hammers keane
il a été fermé les animateurs du site
ont été interpellés l'afer est toujours
à l'instruction et on passe